eventually every single country is going
to be run by somebody who's pro bitcoin
or cryptocurrencies it's just a matter
of time and south korea is the latest
country to go ahead and elect a brand
new president who's coming in and he has
two promises he's going to go ahead and
deregulate bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
he's also going to create favorable tax
treatment this is going to become the
standard model for every single
politician that wants to be elected
globally they realize that their
constituents want this technology they
realize that global adoption is
inevitable if you want to be voted into
office if you want to keep your
political seat you're going to have to
be friendly to these technologies and so
ultimately here's what the south korean
president is vowing to do he's stating
that he's going to attract and develop
crypto unicorns within this country he's
pledging to raise the proposed threshold
for capital gains taxes to kick in only
once you get above the equivalent of 42
450 u.s dollars and then lastly he's
also proposing to go ahead and say that
he's taking legal measures to confiscate
crypto profits gained through
illegitimate means and return them to
the victims now this is incredible to
see from a president at the
international level we've seen countries
like el salvador plug their country in
to the bitcoin standard we've also seen
many politicians here in the united
states go ahead and buy bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies put forward legislation
that would deregulate or increase the
tax environment but ultimately what we
are watching is the south korean
president trying to lead the way he's
not the only person in south korea
though that it tends to be pro bitcoin
or cryptocurrencies we also have a quote
right here from the korea blockchain
association where they say we definitely
welcome his stance and he is confident
about boosting the industry as icos are
banned now we have no choice but to
issue coins in singapore and other
countries ventures and startups will be
able to raise money easily from
investors if that is banned now
ultimately the united states and other
countries aren't going to sit around and
let south korea just take the lead
they're going to compete and that's how
a free market works and so we've got a
quote tweet here from wendy rogers out
of arizona that said arizona should own
more bitcoin than south korea ladies and
gentlemen this is the global game theory
this is the race who's going to buy up
the 21 million bitcoin which nation
state is gonna capitulate who's gonna
jump in the game the people who are
early they benefit the most and the game
theories suggest eventually everyone's
gonna play this game hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time